despite all our current knowledge and
technology all that we understand and
can do up to roughly 67 percent of the
earth's surface to this day remains
unexplored and unseen by human eyes
around 71 percent of earth's surface is
covered by ocean most of us know this we
know that the ocean is very big but when
you realize that up to potentially 95 of
it is still unexplored unmapped and
unseen you also realize that the ocean
is not only huge it is disturbingly
unknown
there is a specific type of phobia known
as the lassophobia which is the intense
fear of deep bodies of water like the
ocean and sea
for some the mere sight of underwater
images can be enough to severely trigger
this phobia for others the feeling might
only be felt when physically swimming in
deep water or out on a boat in the
middle of the ocean
like most phobias there is variance in
the intensity and forms experienced
among sufferers arguably however the
more one learns about the ocean the more
thalassophobia and at least some acute
form is likely to reveal itself in most
of us
being fearful of a beastly eerie state
of matter mostly steeped in darkness
that you are not built to survive in
where dangerous things loom around that
are built to thrive in it doomed to have
your life taken from you by merely going
too deep or staying in too long can just
make a lot of sense
the average depth of the ocean is about
2.3 miles or 3700 meters keyword however
is average the deepest parts of the
ocean run much much deeper deeper than
most of us are likely aware and deeper
than most of us can likely comprehend
taking a brief journey into its depths
starting a bit closer to the surface at
500 meters beneath it we find ourselves
in the middle of what is referred to as
the twilight zone
for reference at this depth if you stood
at the very top of the tip of the one
world trade center the tallest building
in the united states and look down
that's about how deep you would be
submerged at this depth
this is about the maximum depth that
modern nuclear attack submarines
typically travel the deepest most
non-research vessels can traverse
without risking literally being imploded
by the weight of the water pressure
here light rapidly dissipates with each
meter deeper we go and amidst the
increasing darkness we find strange and
unsettling creatures
among which are sperm whales hunting
battling and feeding on giant and
colossal squids all as big as the size
of houses
even more frightening despite their
massive size we didn't even know that
colossal squids existed until 1925
also in this area are otherworldly
bioluminescent creatures that produce
and emit light as a means of hunting and
avoiding being hunted
even more unsettling than what we do
know about this area however is what we
don't a large number of various types of
organisms in this zone remain mostly a
mystery given their elusiveness and the
difficult conditions for research
activity
if we go two times deeper five hundred
more meters at around 1 000 meters under
the surface we reach the midnight zone
this depth would be the equivalent
distance of stacking more than seven of
the great pyramids of giza on top of
each other
at this point light from the surface no
longer reaches here and it is pitch
black
light that traveled around 93 million
miles or about 150 billion meters from
the sun through space through earth's
atmosphere and onto earth's surface at
just one thousand meters or a little
over half a mile under the ocean it has
met its match and been killed off in
entirety
the murkiness and darkness of the water
here is so extreme that massive objects
like sunken ships and airplanes even
when illuminated by powerful lights can
only be seen in mere fractions of tens
of feet and yet in this void life still
lurks
creatures in this zone survive and
thrive in complete darkness under
extreme water pressure with no light
hostile conditions and increasingly rare
prey killing and eating is something
that must be done successfully and
efficiently at every opportunity
strange alien-like creatures like the
anglerfish frilled shark vampire squid
gulper eel and much more all use various
and sometimes gruesome tactics to hunt
eat and avoid being eaten in this zone
as deep and as strange as this zone is
we are not even at ten percent of the
deepest point of the known ocean yet and
the deeper we go life and conditions
only get more mysterious and more
intense
at around four times deeper four
thousand meters under the surface we
reach what is known as the abyssal zone
this zone is where on average the ocean
floor is found although there are still
around 7 000 more meters nearly three
times deeper before we reach the deepest
known area of the ocean
despite all technological development
over the course of modern history
technological achievements that have
taken humans to the moon and back
only just about three years ago in 2019
did a manned vessel reach the floor of
the deepest known area
at 10 934 meters under the surface
investor and formal naval officer victor
viscovo holds the world record for the
deepest any human has ever traveled into
the ocean
in his deep diving submersible here
vascovo reached the deepest point in the
deepest part of the deepest zone of the
known ocean known as challenger deep
located in the mariana trench
for reference the average commercial
airline flight altitude is around 11 000
meters meaning at this point vascova was
as deep in the ocean as you are in the
sky when looking out the window of a
fully ascended commercial flight
despite the seemingly impossible
uninhabitable conditions at this
incomprehensible depth there is still
life found down here creatures like
xenophiophores abnormally large
amphipods and sea cucumbers all exist on
this floor of the void
perhaps even eerier about this area is
that it is the deepest part of the known
ocean but only the known ocean with only
up to around five to ten percent of the
ocean being effectively mapped the
possibility for significantly deeper
parts containing other forms of life
other conditions and ecosystems and who
knows what else is believed by
scientists to be extremely likely
scientists estimate that there are
thousands of marine species we have yet
to discover
how often have you looked up into the
night sky with at least some ominous
curiosity or perhaps even fear of what
is out there what creatures and things
might lurk how far and where it all goes
it is fairly common to wonder and
contemplate about space as the great
remaining unknown but yet on our very
own planet we still don't even really
know what's here with us right now
aliens exist and they are right next to
and beneath us all the time
whether you have the lassophobia or not
there is something deeply unsettling
about the awareness that we share and
inhabit a planet with something we are
so unaware of a vast powerful body of
water containing creatures that look
like they are out of a cosmic horror
film some of which we know of many that
we do not
the ocean is so vast so unexplored and
so hard to travel and see within what
could it hide what potential creatures
who've adapted to hide and pray in these
conditions hide from us a creature
adapted to a completely different world
the ocean is somehow both terrifying and
awe-inspiring grotesque and beautiful
vast and claustrophobic all at the same
time
it reminds us of the strangeness of life
of what it means to exist evolve and
inhabit a planet it reminds us of our
meekness and powerlessness
arguably the source of at least an acute
form of blastophobia runs through and
connects us all the fear and wonder of
the unknown the unseen and the
uncontrollable the feeling of being
helpless and the existential anxiety of
a world so unfamiliar dangerous
uninhabitable and not meant for us that
is just right there next to us above us
and below us
[Music]
this video was sponsored by
curiositystream
for those who aren't familiar
curiositystream is a subscription
streaming service that provides
thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles covering nature
science technology history and much more
it is essentially the netflix or hulu
for those who appreciate
thought-provoking educational content
curiosity stream offers titles from some
of the best and most notable voices and
filmmakers in the world like bethany
hughes in the nile 5 000 years of
history several titles with david
attenborough and genius by stephen
hawking each covering some of life's
biggest smallest and most interesting
places and questions
for those who want to learn from what
they consume but still want to enjoy it
and be entertained curiosity stream is
the streaming service for you it is
available on many if not most platforms
worldwide and it is extremely affordable
at under twenty dollars a year which is
just one dollar and sixty seven cents
per month if you're interested you can
go to curiositystream.com
pow and use promo code pow and save an
additional 25 off the already low
subscription price bringing the total
down to an amazing value of just 14.99 a
year or 125 per month
again if you're interested click the
link in the description and use promo
code pow
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you